l'ancien président de la tunisie moncef
marzouki condamné par contumace à quatre
ans de prison pour atteinte à la sûreté
nationale l'ancien locataire du palais
de carthage et fervent opposant à
l'actuel chef de l'état kai eide dénonce
le site une mascarade la correspondance
à tunis signé deuxième chibli
le jugement d'un misérable magistrats
sur ordre d'un président illégitime les
mots sont forts et assume et se demande
cette marzouki président tunisien de
2011 à 2014 opposant historique de
bourguiba puis de banal il avait été
nommé chef de l'état après la fuite de
ce dernier lors du soulèvement déclenché
fin 2010 dans le viseur de caïds sayed
depuis qu'il avait qualifié le coup de
force du 25 juillet de coup d'état
moncef marzouki n'a cessé de chercher le
soutien des puissances étrangères pour
contrecarrer le projet de l'actuel
locataire du palais de carthage après
une plainte déposée le 14 octobre
dernier à son encontre l'ancien
président tunisien a été condamné hier à
quatre ans de prison avec effet immédiat
pour atteinte à la sécurité extérieure
de l'état un jugement qualifié de
mascarade par l'opposant politique
établie à paris écouter
commentant le jugement rendu par un
misérable magistrats sur ordre d'un
président illégitime j'ai été condamné
plus d'une fois sous le règne de
bourguiba j'ai été jugé plus d'une fois
sous le règne de ben ali est maintenant
un jugement est rendu contre moins
pendant le règne de caïx sayed bourguiba
et ben ali son parti et les causes pour
lesquelles j'ai été jugé en triompher de
la même manière humiliante cet apprenti
dictateur partira et les causes pour
lesquelles j'ai été jugée seront
triomphante les ténèbres se dissiperont
un juge tunisien avait émis début
novembre un mandat d'amener
international contre monde sauf marzouki
deux semaines après la demande du
président saleh daha justice tunisienne
d'ouvrir une enquête sur des
déclarations de l'ancien président de la
république et de retirer son passeport
diplomatique à celui qui figure à ses
yeux parmi les ennemis de la tunisie sur
le plateau de nos confrères de france 24
il avait appelé la france à intervenir
pour stopper ce qu'il qualifie de coup
d'état de violation des acquis de la
révolution de 2011 a commencé par une
atteinte à la constitution de 2014
moncef marzouki et c'était également
félicité d'avoir contribué au report du
sommet de la francophonie qui devait se
tenir à djerba le mois dernier à 76 ans
il a longtemps été le symbole du combat
pour la liberté la démocratie en tunisie
avant de voir son image ternie par son
alliance controversé avec le parti
islamiste ennahda